(audience cheering and clapping)
- I mean--
(Arsema chuckles)
I don't have long enough with you
and I'm sad about it but I'm,
so we're all fans of
"Bridgerton" in general.
Just, before even this show existed.
But I have to tell you, like
this series, like gets better.
Like you, I watched the
first series like no way,
they're gonna do it with the second one.
I was like, oh my god, no way.
They're gonna do the third one.
This is my favorite one.
- No way.
- Wow.
- It is, so no, way, way, way it is so good.
So tell us, or I know who you play
but tell everybody who you play
and like what it's really
about your character.
- So I play a young Queen Charlotte.
Queen Charlotte is obviously
the queen in "Bridgerton."
So I play the younger version
of Golda Rosheuvel's portrayal of her.
- [Corey] She is.
- [Arsema] There she is.
- Oh my God.
(audience cheers)
Looking phenomenal.
- She's pretty cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that's her.
She's pretty, yeah, she's 17.
She's come from Germany.
- Kind of a progressive mind for the time.
- [India] Yeah, completely.
- Yeah.
- And very kind of inquisitive
and really lovely to play someone
who's not just one-dimensional
and she's got so many
different layers and yeah,
very lucky to be a part
of it and to play her.
- And it's intense.
Y'all, yeah, I was like, what?
Yeah, okay, tell everybody who is here,
Lady Danbury.
- Yes, yeah, I'm young
Lady Agatha Danbury.
In the show, you kind of see
her in a much different version
than you saw in, (Arsema chuckles) yes.
(audience cheers)
So like in "Bridgerton,"
she's this extremely powerful woman.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, you see her
with her cane and her hat.
And then to see her in this
show, she is just not there yet.
And you kind of see her become that.
So to see what a journey is like
in a young Black woman is
so just exciting to play.
- And the pressure and the weight.
I love how this story,
it has a lot of parallels
for just like life now too.
You know?
And there's a lot of messaging in there.
Not in a way that beats you over the head,
but tells a story to where you
make, it's thought provoking.
- Yeah.
- I just love how you see her
in a completely different light, you know?
And you did a great job.
It was really, really great.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
Thanks.
- Corey, you can tell
everybody who you play.
But oh my gosh,
I feel like you out of
the entire cast just,
they put you through the
ringer emotionally, like.
- Yeah, it wasn't easy.
- [Kelly] No.
- Yeah, these guys made
it very easy, easier.
Yeah, not so much India.
(all laugh)
No, it was great, yeah, he is charming.
He has that string to his bow,
but he, the man that he, there he is.
- Yeah, King George.
- Yeah.
- Sorry, that--
- And you play King George, yeah.
- Yes.
- Just looking fantastic.
Here's the thing.
I know y'all all look beautiful
and gorgeous and whatever.
How uncomfortable were you?
Don't lie.
- Give me a little Arsema,
like, where do we go?
Where do we stop?
- There's so many choices.
The shoes, the skirts
themselves were heavy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- The corsets and then the wigs.
- Which were like another good ten pounds.
- I mean, they did a great job.
You look incredible.
But I was like,
there is no way they're
not crying deep inside.
(Arsema laughs)
- Yeah, it really helps it, I
think I speak for all of us.
It helps get into character.
It creates authentic character.
'Cause you're not having to think,
how would they feel in this corset.
You are feeling it.
- 'Cause really wanna die.
(Kelly laughs)
- Exactly, yeah.
So it doesn't just look fantastic.
It helps in every way.
(audience cheers)
- Where were you originally from?
You, I feel like you've lived all over.
- Yeah, so I was born in Atlanta, Georgia.
- Okay.
- And then, yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That one.
- That is my--
- One person.
- That's your mom.
- It's my mom.
- It's your mom, oh my God, what's up mom?
(audience cheers)
Arsema's mom is in the
audience, all right.
- So she's going to like
double check everything
that I say right now.
- Yeah.
- So it's 100% true.
But yeah, then I, we, I moved to New York
and then grew up a lot in,
around Sub-Saharan Africa.
So Kenya, Benin, Togo, Uganda,
and then came back to the States.
- That can be hard as a kid traveling,
but what a cool experience to be able to,
like, what's your favorite
place, if you had to pick.
- Benin is probably my favorite.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's like this small beautiful
country in West Africa,
Francophone and it's like the
beach is the entire country.
You can--
- That's beautiful.
You're constantly on vacation.
- Exactly.
- [Kelly] Even when you're not.
- That's how we should live.
Is it true though that
you and some castmates,
did y'all rent a Vrbo?
Like after y'all taped?
- Yeah.
- We did, no, we, during the taping.
- [Kelly] During it.
- [Corey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
So we had like two weeks left
on the job and we thought,
"Why not spend it all together?"
We got along like a house
on fire most of the time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But yeah, we had a really
good time and we haunted.
I almost told the whole secret--
- No, that's what I wanna get to--
- Of the story.
- Here's the thing, I heard
that the place that you stayed
was haunted.
- [India] Was haunted, yeah.
- Okay.
- Well it wasn't, but we thought it was.
- Why did you think it
was, what's that story?
- His name is Freddy Dennis.
- [India] And he's in the show.
- And he's not here with us today.
- Yes, he is in the show.
- Yeah, no, he's a trickster.
- [Kelly] Oh, he's a prankster.
- And a fool and a fiend.
- [India] But we love him.
- We love him, yeah, he's amazing.
I live with Freddy now,
but, yeah, he's--
- Wait, does,
so he's the guy that jumps
out and scares you a lot?
- Yeah.
- That's not my kind of dude.
- [India] No.
- [Corey] No.
(Arsema laughs)
- [Kelly] Not my kind of dude.
- He turned the lights off
when she was in the shower.
- In the shower.
Really dangerous.
I'm not funny.
- What if you'd been shaving?
- Exactly.
- Imagine.
- Yes, exactly.
Yeah, but we had a really good time.
- Oh my God.
So he didn't, you didn't
know he was doing it though
and they kept saying
the place was haunted.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- And you're just like
naked in the shower.
Like what?
- Yeah, and I ran down in my towel.
I was like, "Guys, this
isn't funny anymore.
"Now it's serious."
But it was a joke.
But we had a great time.
- [Kelly] Oh, God.
- Yeah, it was a great time.
- That's so fun that you
had such great chemistry
that you ended up, you're like,
"Let's just do this for
the last couple weeks."
That's awesome.
- Yeah (indistinct).
- What a fun, yeah,
it is rare though, it's so good.
Arsema, so I heard that you
got to meet one of your idols.
Is this right, at the
(indistinct), this year?
- Yeah.
- Serena William?
- At the, I mean, I
didn't get to meet her.
I must just say that, as a disclaimer.
- [Kelly] You got to--
- We made eye contact.
(audience applauds)
And then in the most cosmic of timing,
my heel just like broke
and I fell to the floor as if I was,
yep, that's the shoe.
- [Kelly] It happens to the best of us.
- Yes, and it looked
just like I had fainted
as though I had just seen
Serena Williams, which she was--
- [Kelly] Was it like
right in front of her?
- It was like, we were across the room.
She's tall and because of
the platform, so was I.
And I remember her looking at me
and me looking at her, and
I'm like, are we gonna?
And then I just was like, and
then everyone's like, whoa.
And I'm like, okay, I dropped something--
- Then Satan takes hold of the moment.
- Yeah.
- The devil was alive on that day.
- The devil came through.
Thank y'all so much.
I love, I know that y'all
are off to do something
and I love that you took
the time to do the show
because I really appreciated everything.
Just as like someone who loves
a bit of escapism in their life
and to make something just,
it's just so well done.
The acting, the art
direction, the storytelling.
It's so well done.
So thank you for doing that for all of us.
(audience applauds)
It's so entertaining.
Everybody, you have got to
watch "Queen Charlotte."
It's the best one out of the "Bridgerton,"
It's a "Bridgerton" story.
It's on Netflix.
It's a great part of this series.